MIHAI IONESCU: Hi there.
My name is Mihai Ionescu.
And I'm a Developer Advocate
at Google, working on the
Google Wallet team.
Today, I'll cover two APIs, the
Digital Goods API and the
Instant Buy API.
And we'll look at various ways
to integrate them into your
applications or online store.
First, what is use
Google Wallet?
Conceptually, Google Wallet is
an effort to digitize all the
physical information available
in your wallet, stuff like
credit cards, coupons,
loyalty cards--
it could even be movie tickets,
airline tickets--
and take all that information
in digital form and put it
into the cloud.
The benefit of having it into
the cloud is that it will be
available anywhere,
on any device.
So that is a very powerful
concept.
Once a customer has access to
that information, anywhere and
on any device, then the online
purchasing experience, for
example, can be dramatically
improved.
And with an improved experience,
you will see a
dramatic rise in conversion
rates and sales.
So that is all great news for
merchants and developers.
Who doesn't want to
make more money?
And that is where the two Google
Wallet APIs I'm going
to talk about are focusing.
So let's start with the
Digital Goods API.
The Digital Goods API is
the simpler of the two.
But a lot of the principles
and concepts
apply to both of them.
So I'll make sure, if there's
something completely
different, I will
point it out.
So what is the Digital
Goods API?
Well, it's a buy flow that is
optimized for digital content.
And that means that you won't
have to worry about
implementing your own buy flow
with the risk engine or having
PCI compliance.
The entire API should be very
simple to integrate and let
you focus on your core
competency in developing your
game or your online store.
So I pointed out some of the
principles behind our APIs.
And I want to emphasize
them now.
One of them is to build
a very streamlined
experience for the customer.
And we've noticed that, the more
you optimize the number
of clicks and you reduce the
number of clicks, the higher
the conversion rates are.
People will tend to finish a
purchase, if you make it
simple for them, if you don't
take them to different
websites and make them click
a lot of buttons.
So both the Digital Goods API
and the Instant Buy API are
following these principles.
And they are trying to keep the
customer engaged, either
in the game or stay on your
store and complete the
transaction in as few
steps as possible.
One of the second principles
was to make it dead simple.
The integration should be as
easy as adapting, copy-pasting
one of our samples and making
just a few modifications on
your site and being ready
to place a transaction.
And here I have a very simple
snippet from the Digital Goods
API, which is not
that different
than a final version.
You could literally use some
of the snippets in this
presentation later on and
have a functional,
working payment system.
Another important principle
was to keep it affordable.
And in the Digital Goods API,
the pricing structure is one
of the most aggressive
in the industry, with
fees as low as 1.9%.
The Instant Buy API,
on the other hand,
is absolutely free.
And you will see why,
later in the talk.
Let's have a quick look at
the Instant Buy API.
So why is it different than
the Digital Goods API?
Well, it offers you more control
over the buy flow.
The Digital Goods API has the
simplest buy flow possible.
All you had to do was add
the Buy with Google
button to your page.
And once the customer clicked
on the button, you knew you
would get your money.
There was nothing else for you
to do it than acknowledge that
you received the money.
The Instant Buy API goes
a step further.
And for merchants who have
a more complex in-house
inventory management system or
purchasing system, allows them
to use their own payment
processors.
So it will provide you with a
virtual one-time card, with a
proxy card that can
be used only for
that particular purchase.
And then, you will charge the
card and do all the necessary
post-transaction processings
in-house, thus giving you more
control over managing your
entire post-processing system.
Similarly, as the Digital
Goods API, we strive to
provide a very streamlined
customer experience.
So the buy flow should
be frictionless.
And in this case, it's
just two clicks
to complete an order.
Put the item in your
shopping cart, then
select to buy with Google.
Then you would confirm
the order.
And we provide the merchant with
shipping information and
the virtual card information.
And then, with an extra click,
you complete the order.
Now, let's look at how we
integrate the Digital Goods
API and the Instant Buy API.
And let's start with the Digital
Goods API, the simpler
of the two.
An important concept that is
applicable to both APIs is the
JSON Web Token, short
form of JWT.
Or it's pronounced jot.
And what is a JWT?
It's a compact representation
of a message.
It's a very nice way to
communicate between your
application and Google server
and transfer payment
information back and forth.
And how does JSON Web
Token look like?
Well, it starts with a JSON data
structure, like we see
here on the left side.
And then, URL encodes it and
cryptographically signs the
JSON structure.
And you end up with a string
of weird looking
characters, like here.
But conceptually, the JWT is
composed of a Header, the
Content that we see here,
and the Signature.
And the Signature, you use it
along the way, to verify that
the information you receive
matches the origin.
So only you know the secret
that you use to
sign the JSON content.
And then, at the origin, you
verify that it has not been
tampered with along the way.
I can show you briefly
one of our tools on
our Developers site.
We have a JWT decoder.
You can use it to decode any
kind of JWT, value JWT.
I have some random JWT here.
If you click on the Decode
button, you will see that it
nicely shows you
the Header, the
Content, and the Signature.
The Header contains just some
information about the
algorithm used to encode it.
And then the Content
of the claims is
the usual JSON structure.
And then, the Signature is what
you will later use to
verify that your JWT
has been signed
with the correct secret.
We'll come back to
this one later.
Let's see how a single order JWT
looks like, for a Digital
Goods order.
So in this example, you see a
very nice JSON with a lot of
field stuff, like who is the
merchant, the type of payment.
In this case, it's just
a single item
that you will sell.
We have fields, such as issue
at and an expiring time for
the JWT and then a request
structure with all the item
information-- in this
case, name,
description, price, and currency.
The API is available in 18
countries and in nine
currencies.
So this field, the currency
code could be
anything other than USD.
And we've got an extra field
here of seller data, which is
quite important.
You can place, in this field,
any information, any merchant
information that you could
later use to identify the
transaction, either a user
ID or a time stamp.
And all this information will be
later mirrored back to you,
when the transaction is over.
So you know exactly what
happened when the transaction
was placed, under what
circumstances.
So all of this JSON information,
as you see it
here, we'll pass it to
an encode function.
There are a lot of JWT libraries
out there, that can
encode and decode
JSON Web Tokens.
And we'll sign it with
a Seller Secret.
You will get a Seller Secret
when you sign up for a
merchant account.
And keep that Seller Secret in
a safe place, literally on
your server, because it's used
to verify that the information
is correct.
And you don't want someone
else to tamper with your
transaction data.
Let's have a look at another
type of JWT.
In this case, it's a
subscription JWT.
And I've highlighted some of the
fields that are different.
It's a little bit bigger but
not that much bigger.
So what changed was the type
of transaction in the JWT.
And then we added an extra
structure called Recurrence,
which specifies how often the
subscription should look recur
and at what price.
So you see in the JSON structure
is maintained.
And the encoding takes place.
There's the same strategy
to encode the JSON.
As I mentioned earlier,
you could literally
copy-paste this code.
And with very few modifications,
you'll be able
to have a working
digital payment
system on your website.
It's that simple.
So once you have created the
JWTs and encoded them on your
server, then you're
ready to send the
transaction to Google.
And that is one of the simplest
ways I've ever seen
to send transaction
information over.
So this API is basically
just one function call.
It doesn't get any simpler
than that.
And the function call is
google.payments.inapp.buy.
And to this function, you will
pass your generated JWT that
we've seen earlier.
And two handlers, one for
success, one for failure, that
will be called on your client
when the transaction is over.
And you link this handler
with a button.
Once the button is pressed,
then the transaction
information would be sent
over to Google.
And let's have a look
at how this would
actually work in practice.
So first, on our Developers
site, we have a nice demo, a
nice way for you to play with
various JSON Web Tokens.
In this form here,
it's editable.
And let's say we want
to change the item
price to $30 from $20.
And if you click on Generate,
you will notice that, on the
right side, the JSON here
will change slightly.
See, it changed.
Something changed here because
we have a different field now.
So this is literally the entire
code that you could
copy-paste and put on your
website, to add a Buy with
Google Digital Goods button.
And the button is here.
And it calls this function
here, which in turn calls
payments.inapp.buy and passes
it the JSON Web
Token and two handlers.
So let's try this in practice,
so a simple code like this in
a very simple web page.
So on our Developers site, we
also have a nice list of
samples that you could use as
a starting point for your
implementation.
And let's try a purchase
that is a very
simple digital purchase.
I click the Buy button.
And the dialogue shows up.
I can change my payment
information if I want to.
But generally, everything
is all set up.
I can just click Buy.
My JSON, my encoded JWT
now goes to Google.
Google processes the transaction
and sends back a
confirmation.
So my entire transaction
is now complete.
Is there anything left to do?
Well, yes.
You have success and failure
handlers here
on the client side.
But generally, they are not
enough to ensure that the
transaction is secure, because
anyone with a debugger, such
as Firefox or Chrome Developer
Tools, can issue a success
code and try to get your
digital item for free.
So because of that, there is
another way to make sure that
a transaction is secure.
And that is to acknowledge the
purchase notification on the
server site.
And that is done through a
callback that Google sends you
after the transaction is over.
So on you server, where you
prepare your JSON, you can
also set up a Post Back Handler
that will receive the
transaction notification
from Google.
And here I have an example.
It is Python, but you can
adapt it to Java or PHP.
And it shows how simple it
is to acknowledge the
notification from Google.
The notification comes
back as a post.
And it will be another JWT.
You will decoded it with your
Seller Secret and make sure
everything looks OK.
And as I mentioned earlier,
it'll be the original
transaction JWT plus
an Order ID.
You will look at the JWT,
make sure it's correct.
You will get the Order ID.
And you will have to respond
back to Google with the Order
ID to complete the payment.
You will have 10 seconds to do
that, which is more than
enough, in the vast
majority of cases.
And once you respond with the
Order ID, the transaction will
be complete.
And then, Google will call
your client handlers.
And in that case, you
know that the
transaction is secure.
You have the money.
And you can give the item
to the customer.
So it is always recommended
that you use both types of
handlers, the Server Site
Handler and the Client
Handler, to conform the
transaction and update your
internal game or application
state.
And that's it, a very
simple to use API.
It took me probably less than
10 minutes to explain it.
You can copy-paste the
code from the slides.
But the best is if you go on our
Developers site and look
at the Samples page.
We have examples in
Java and Python.
And you can take them and very
easily adapt them to your
special case.
Now, let's have a look at a
slightly more complicated API.
And that is the Instant
Buy API.
So first, I want to go over a
very important concept here.
The Instant Buy API allows you
to use your existing payment
processor to complete
a transaction.
So the buy flow is slightly
different.
It's not an end-to-end buy flow,
like the Digital Goods
API, where everything
was done by Google.
In this case, you will initiate
the buy flow using
the customer's wallet.
But you will end up processing
the transaction yourself.
This is done using
a proxy card.
It is a one-time, virtual card,
a MasterCard branded
card, that Google
will send you.
And you can charge this only
for this particular
transaction.
So in order to get that one-time
card, you have to go
through several steps.
And the first step is to get
what we call a Masked Wallet.
A Masked Wallet contains masked
payment credentials
that you can use in
your application.
And that is a masked credit card
number or partial credit
card number that you can display
to the customer and
shipping information.
You can use the shipping
information to compute tax and
shipping costs.
And the masked payment
information can be used by the
customer to select which card,
which payment instrument, they
want to use for the
transaction.
So before you set up anything,
you need to create a JWT, like
in the other cases, where you'll
communicate with Google
the information you
are requested
in the Masked Wallet.
Once you set up that
information, you can create
your Shopping Cart page, where
you will have a Buy with
Google page.
And clicking that Buy with
Google page will send your
Masked Wallet request
to Google.
And you will receive back the
Masked Wallet information.
So a very important concept
to notice here--
you will have to have that
information ready, before
rendering the Buy with
Google button.
Now, rendering the Buy
with Google button
is also very simple.
You can do it statically
or dynamically.
Statically, we have a special
g:wallet element that you can
insert into your web page.
Or you can do it dynamically
through JavaScript tool and a
library function call.
And note that, in both cases,
you have a request JWT for
that Masked Wallet
information.
That will be passed on to
Google, once the customer
clicks on the Buy with
Google button.
So at this point, you're
all set up.
You have created your Buy
with Google button.
You are requesting particular
information about that customer.
And that could be shipping
address, if you're
shipping a real good.
You can skip the shipping
address, if you're-- let's
say-- just providing
a digital service.
And you would need to get back
to the partial credit card
number, the masked credit card
number, so that the customer
selects and acknowledge that
they want to pay with that
particular instrument.
So now, once that information
goes to Google, Google will
send you back the
Masked Wallet.
And in this case, you will see
it in visual form here.
So now you have shipping
information.
And you have a partial credit
card number or more.
The customer can use the change
buttons to select
different shipping addresses, if
they are available in their
Google Wallet Account or
different instruments,
different credit cards, again,
if they are available.
Once the customer has settled
on a particular shipping
information and payment
information, you can compute
the exact shipping charges
and tax and provide a
total charge amount.
In the case of a Masked Wallet
request, the charge amount was
just an estimate.
Generally, it would exclude
shipping and tax, because you
don't know at that point
what the tax or
shipping charges are.
So once you get in this state,
you have a Place Order button,
where the customer confirms
the purchase.
Once that Place Order button
is pressed, then you will
request what we call
a Full Wallet.
A Full Wallet returns back
to you the credit card
information needed to actually
charged the purchase.
That will be the proxy card,
the one-time use card.
And you'll have all the
information you need to
actually process it with your
preferred payment processor.
So once we go to the Full
Wallet, as I said, it has the
exact amount that you
need to charge, that
includes tax and shipping.
And all the details you call
back include the billing
address and the card number,
which will allow you to make
the exact charge.
So this is very powerful,
especially for merchants who
have their own in-house
payment processing.
Or they have a very customized
and sophisticated
post-transaction system
or inventory system.
In that case, the Digital Goods
solution probably was
not enough.
It's a very simple solution.
And they would have had to build
on top of it, anyway.
So in this way, the merchants
have access to a very powerful
API, which gives them more
control over the entire
transaction flow.
So with that, I think we covered
all the important
aspects of the two APIs.
How do you get started?
It's very easy.
I pointed out the documentation
earlier.
I'm going to say it again.
It's at
developers.google.com/commerce,
where you'll find separate
documentation for the Digital
Goods API and the
Instant Buy API.
With that, we have tutorials.
We have sample code, that you
can very easily reuse.
We have demo codes.
We have Sandbox, where you can
actually test your entire
integration with test
credit cards.
So everything will look the same
as in reality, as in a
production environment, except
that no money exchanges hands.
The test credit cards will not
involve a real transaction.
You can create a merchant
account also.
We have steps how to do that
from the documentation.
Once you do that, you
can start testing.
You can start implementing.
And you can start selling.
And with that, you can
start making money.
And that's what we want everyone
to do, to be happy
and profit.
And if you have questions,
you have suggestions.
We have links on our page
to our blog to our
social media accounts.
And we have regular sessions
on Google Developers Live.
We will see you then,
and until then, bye.